Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host Rawkode.
Today we are continuing our series of running
Laravel on Kubernetes.
Trying to make sure that we tackle all
the different edge cases and real scenarios that
people need to solve to be able to
scale properly. Today specifically, we're gonna be taking
a look at how we can get metrics
out
of our Laravel application
and use that for some auto scaling plus
one of my guests Alex has got some
random ideas to do that with key workers
too. So it's gonna be a little bit
of fun and a little bit of well
what the hell are we doing but we're
working out. So let's introduce my guests for
today. I am joined by Alex Bowers and
Kieran McNulty. Hello.
Hi. Thank
you for joining me again today.
We'll, as always, we'll just quickly do introductions
and feel free to use as little or
as much time as you want starting with
Alex.
Yeah. I'm just a Laravel developer, I've known
David for a few couple of years now,
but very we see each of a once
a year and I keep asking about Kubernetes
and eventually we might start doing some of
these videos and here we are.
K. I'll turn in.
You hear me? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Good. We're
all good. Hi. I'm Kieran. I'm a consultant.
My background's in development, but I do a
lot of coaching around agile and testing. And
the
actual deployment bit is
nice to be involved in because it's a
little bit outside my comfort zone.
Yeah. I think today What else?
Yeah, today is definitely an episode of fun
discovery as we try and tackle the scaling
aspects of running any, I guess any application
on Kubernetes. This is obviously specific to PHP
and Laravel today but the same
stuff that we're gonna do the same concepts
will work across everything and already now we
can see their first message and then discuss
channel,
discord have a bug in their stream overlay
which means all the
names of people are object objects. So that's
awesome. Was that you Alex or was that
someone else? Somebody else, somebody called John I
believe. I'll keep the chat open.
Hey
It
would be good if I could see your
name but I'll reach out to Discord and
see if we get that fixed. Regardless, we're
testing out the discuss live chat thingy on
our stream, we'll see how we get on,
I may move it at some point and
of course if you're watching on YouTube, please
feel free to drop any questions that you
have into the comment section and we will
tackle them as we go.
Now, why don't we try and recap where
we got to last time and then maybe
best to do that through the power of
code because
we I think we got quite far, didn't
we Alex?
Yeah, we got very
like a good amount was done. We had
at the end of it, we had migrations
working. We had
queues set up and running through.
Those were the two main things. There was
a couple of the things that we managed
to cover as well, but can't remember what
they are now.
But, yeah, we made some good progress on
a production level application last
last time.
Well, let's see what's still working because who
knows?
Let's
see what did where did I put everything?
All of the all of the roots are
all of the features that we built last
time are in the roots folder. So we
can see that to see what we covered.
And so where where did we put the
manifests?
Oh, it was inside of slash
resources ops.
Oh, yeah. Hey, I'm looking for my my
OPT directory, but there we go. So we've
got our Docker files. We've got a config
map. We have a deployment.
We actually
have our cron job which was to run.
What was this for?
So Rawkode has a job scheduler built in.
So for every minute it can you can
the scheduler gets called, and you from there,
can dispatch different jobs in PHP for whatever
you need to do. Alright. So you can
see the example for that in
app console
kernel, I think it is. Does Laravel have
a way of
instead scheduling them directly,
scheduling the jobs directly from Chrome?
Yes. So every
single
command that you create in Laravel,
you can just hit using, like, PHP artisan
command name. Right. Right. And you could do
that directly from the cron. But if you
want to, for example,
add conditional logic, so you do a database
query
to see Yeah. Do do you need to
care about running this?
Yeah. You you do that in the the
kernel the console kernel.
Yeah. Yeah. And it also has some nice
syntax structure
where you can do like,
you can use the words like every evening
rather than trying to figure out what random
stars and commas and numbers mean.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool. I think I'm all caught up which
is useful.
I also see that I need to make
file which has two commands for both in
these containers. So why don't we get them
built? Let's apply our Kubernetes manifest directory and
see if anything blows up. Hopefully we just
get our application working
and then we can start getting some metrics
out of it.
It was left in a working state so
I'd be
I'd be upset if it breaks in the
two weeks Yeah.
Build NGINX
and build
FBM.
Smarter person would have done this prior, but
still.
I'm sure it won't take too long though.
Although, whenever I see an NPM command, I
do get slightly worried.
NPM CI, so it's not it shouldn't be
doing as much as a normal install would
be because it uses lock file to
have specific version. So you shouldn't have to
do any dependency resolution I don't think.
Alright. Well, we'll get these Well, I'm saying
that we're we are thirty seconds in so,
know,
take what you want from that I guess.
Well, my Mac has an airplane mode where
it's trying to take off. So we'll see.
I can hear the fans over the headphones
which is never a good sign.
That's the sign that using node, isn't it?
Well, I wondered with your shiny M1 Mac,
Keenan, do your fans ever go?
I heard as much better.
I've had it.
Oh god, when did I buy it? I've
had a couple of months and I've heard
the fans once.
Wow.
They sell one without fans only now as
well so.
Yeah. The edge is That's brave when I
can do in any node stuff. That's brave.
Alright. Here we go. It looks like it's
now finishing at least one of our images.
Left I
left some CAD software running overnight, and that's
when the fans ran.
That's
the only time.
Hopefully,
they bring out another one. I'll buy the
second version, but I'm not buying the first.
Yeah. They'll bring out an amazing one at
the of the year and I'll be jealous.
Yeah. Well, I'm I'm getting a new one.
Oh god.
Next month in March. Sometime in March or
April. Alright.
So without doubt, it'll be about May or
June when the next one comes out, just
as mine's been delivered.
So, yeah. We'll see.
If you need to use it to do
docker stuff day to day, it's still not
quite there.
We don't use docker in the company at
the moment. We're moving towards that. So hopefully,
by the time we get that new environment
set up and stuff,
it's a bit more stable.
Our compelling extensions.
I may go get a coffee.
Do you clear up your Docker cache quite
often or something, David?
Yeah. Every thirteen seconds probably.
I'm always well because I always go into
my Docker settings and just click reset everything
and just kill it.
I do that far too often. I do
it my phone too.
Like when I was on Android I would
clear all when I'm on the task manager.
Now I'm on iOS there's no clear all
button but I just keep swiping apps away
anyway and people keep telling me that's actually
bad
but it's just I guess habit more than
anything.
Yeah. It's meant to use more power to
start the app back up again, isn't it?
I know it's just something I've always done.
Not using it, close it. Not using it,
close it.
And I do it with Docker too. I'm
always killing containers and images.
I think I'm the opposite. I I usually
at some point noticed my machine's running really
slowly and has no disk.
And do Docker years. I'm
rocking about 20 gig of disk space left.
I'm slowly just like working my way through
various things clear and stuff out. I don't
even think I use 20 gig.
It's painful.
I can't have any icons on my desktop
either. I can't have any downloads in the
downloads folder. I just clean everything up really
quickly.
It's probably better that way then the alternative
which is I have just my downloads folders
everything I've ever downloaded.
Useful or not.
Alright. There we go. And
I'm sure everyone's really disappointed because they were
loving that conversation where I was talking about
files on my desktop. But
at least I've got my command history and
history so that's full. So we're gonna do
a kip control apply or don't wanna do
everything.
I'm assuming we built it in a way
that that should be alright.
Looks good.
Wow, this is gonna work.
Alright. And that containers are It's not like
you had no thing.
Yeah. That that and it's gonna fix itself.
I think that's just my SQL and the
Ruby's not happy yet. I'm hoping.
Is this local Kubernetes?
It is local Kubernetes.
Yeah.
Alright. Let's take a look at one of
these. Well, the last one says initializing.
Let's try it. I'll look one more time.
There we go. Perfect.
Nice.
Okay.
So
now we've got I'm assuming a service.
Let's port forward
SVC.
Oh, we didn't create a Laravel service. Okay.
So we'll just port forward to a pod.
Eighty eighty on port 80.
We should just have our application.
Maybe I'll hide that. Yep. That was exactly
what I built. Yep.
Alright. This should be read.
Not gonna make us a million dollars by
any means but functional for today.
So what we wanna do now is well,
we don't really want to
you know, we talk about all scale, normally
we talk about scaling up but I wanna
equally emphasize that we wanna be able to
scale down when required too. So right now
we are running five replicas
of our Laravel application and I'm the only
user. So maybe this is slightly overkill.
So what we wanna do
is scale this up and down accordingly.
That
makes sense? Mhmm. Mhmm.
Okay. How do we do it?
Okay. Yeah. Good good first question, Alan.
Okay. So why don't we start with a
naive approach?
Right. No. No. Let's let's go back to
that question. Like, what what do we think
we want from auto scaling? When when do
we scale up? What's the best way to
scale up?
When there aren't enough resources
at the current scale level for what we're
trying to do.
Yeah. I like the like the usage of
resources there. Definitely something that we can use
to determine whether we we scale up.
Yes.
Or when performance isn't good enough at the
current scale level?
Yes. So you know we're getting into the
conversation that like like when we talk about
what how is how is the application performing
for our end users?
So when I say naive auto scaling, resources
is normally the first approach people say well,
you know if I'm running out of CPU
or memory then we probably want to be
able to scale accordingly because we think that
we think the performance will be
degraded in some way,
but I like to work with end users.
So we're gonna try and tackle both I
think
because
maybe. Okay, let's scale it down. Let's see
what happens.
Does anybody know any HTTP load testing tools?
I probably should have asked that. I use
one called siege.
Siege. Is that the patchy one, isn't it?
Maybe. No. It's that's just a patchy bench.
One I use is let me find it.
Otherwise,
I'm just gonna go to Google and search
for Rust.
This is
what I use to just it's by something
called Joe dog siege.
Okay.
I'll I'll post it in the discord.
Why my alt tab not working to my
terminal? Did it goes to Versus Code?
I'll restart that in a minute. Alright. Let's
reapply this over the top
and that should scale down.
Good. So now we're just gonna run one.
I guess I'm not even sure, this is
where my Laravel knowledge will probably let me
down with the first kind of scaling scenario
but you know,
if I throw siege at our application which
is running on a single pod inside of
a local Kubernetes cluster
and had it with 10,000 requests, am I
likely to see CPU and memory usage increase?
Probably not massively. It depends on how many
concurrent requests, I guess, and what the v
plus allocation is. But obviously, our home page
there is literally just returning the string hello
world.
Maybe we change the code to make it,
I don't know, like calculate an m d
five ten thousand times. It's just something so
it actually does some work. It might be
worth doing.
Yeah. Do we do we want it to
create database
load as well?
Maybe. I don't believe there's there's no models
or anything set up on this. Oh, actually,
no. There was. There were models.
Yay. Yeah. Because we created some post blog
posts, didn't we?
Yeah.
Yeah. We can look at the data upload.
If you open up the
I can't. The blog post forward. I can't.
If you open up the roots file, the
roots web PHP file, that's got all of
the endpoints that I created in there.
Yeah. There we go.
We do have stuff in the database.
Alright. You sent me this geodog slash siege.
Is there a brew package for it?
Yeah. Believe so.
Yeah. Okay. Cool. Let's see if we can
run that and let's just model. You know,
we're just gonna in a very simple basis,
look at the CPU and memory utilization and
then we'll see if we can cause a
very naive scaling situation.
Again, more stuff I should have done up
front, but yeah.
If you if you have it loading stuff
from the database, PHP will perform badly
because it will block
waiting for the responses, which ties up processes.
So that that will kill the sort of
concurrency.
It's alright. It's better than it used to
be.
Yeah. Can you remember what we put this
on? Was it 7.4
or eight point zero
PHP?
I
don't know.
Actually, I can check the Docker file, can't
I? Yeah. Yeah. Resources
ops,
Docker,
FBM,
7.4.
Yeah.
Quite a lot of improvements were made in
eight point zero.
But
hopefully 7.4 means we see better
examples for scaling because it'll be worth performance,
I guess.
Saw it the other day. One of the
features that's landing in 8.1 has a 20%
speed improvement
real world
for some of them. I think that's sort
of linked
linked caching of,
like, inheritance files and classes or something, I
think.
But I don't think it's like your page
will be 20% better. I think it's what
was what was like a very small portion
of your, like, load time is 20% better
than it was on that small section.
Yeah. So real world Pages are the one
we're at.
Pages are the one we're looking at that's
just doing CPU.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. Our application oh, we got a comment
from a guy who mentioned, hey, for load
testing. I've actually heard people mention that before.
I'll check it out another time, but for
now I'll run siege just because I've got
it installed.
We're gonna hit local host on 8080.
And if I just do this, I'm assuming
it's gonna magically just start firing requests at
it.
Mean, is that is that it working? I
think so. If you cancel it, tells you
then how many requests it did I think.
I'm not I'm not really sure. I normally
pass through dash c and dash t.
Well, our availability
four dash c is how many concurrency is.
Well, it looks like we potentially got failed
requests even with just the basic settings there.
So Nice.
Yeah.
I think it was working.
Concurrently 13.
On our availability dropped to 44% that time.
Wow. So it's actually that's okay.
Our response time is eleven seconds. Is that
is that can't be No. That might be
milliseconds.
Can't be eleven seconds shortly. I would hope
not. Right? It's done nothing.
Because that homepage is just a bit the
page which says like, this is my
this should be red or whatever.
Okay.
Well,
yeah. Okay. Let's try let's try and scale
this then. So
we can pull up the documentation
for so Kubernetes has a primitive
called an HPA.
This is the horizontal pod auto scaler
which
out of the box doesn't do an awful
lot but we can do
CPU
based scaling
as you know the
the cubelet that's just running containers does have
some form of metrics coming out of it
and it knows what they're being used.
Hopefully we've got an example of Yamal here
that we can kind of steal.
Computer said no.
There we go. Example. Yes since last hit
that.
Computer said no.
Yeah.
Well they actually use PHP
I have a square root function to try
and trigger CPU intensive computation.
Well.
As our deployment, as our service, let's get
down to the good stuff.
Where is it?
They're using the auto skill command to create
one. Alright. Let's go with that.
Deployment,
Laravel
example.
Why did we give it such a verbose
name?
Or didn't we? I don't remember.
Yeah.
Project.
Thank you. And you can see now we
have a horizontal pod auto scaler. So what
we can do is
get our HPA,
which has got the same name.
Take a look at it in YAML.
And this
is our spec.
So it has max replicas of 10,
minimum replicas of one, of course we always
want one of these
and the naive implementation
as as the target or the CPU utilization
goes above 50%,
we're gonna want more of these.
So
in theory
we have one pod now. I wonder if
we just run siege again and watch that
and we'll see an auto scaling event kickoff.
Are we feeling confident with that?
No, me neither. Okay.
Wrong split. Let's go this way.
I'll just run the pod watch here
and I'll run siege again here.
I won't get any jokes just now.
I
have but not appropriate for stream so.
It's always the worst question to ask somebody.
You got joke? Too much pressure. I've got
a question about the config.
It
does each of these pods do the Laravel
pods have an NGINX and an FPM in
them?
No. It's just PHP FPM in there. And
then the NGINX one
loads it across from the FPM
image.
Look. It's scaled.
That's
nice.
Okay. So I think I know where Kieran's
question was going. So I'm gonna try and
magically
discuss what you were thinking there as if
we do it.
Maybe you can't see it from the screen.
Alright. Okay. Do it the long way.
Oh, no. That doesn't scale. Did it?
It said it was creating a new container
though.
Oh, that's our job. Our cron job. That's
that's the cron job one. Yeah. Okay. Alright.
So let's work it why it doesn't scale
yet. So Kieran, I think your question was
based on the HPA configuration that we've seen
up here is that which containers are using
to determine if the CPU went too high.
Is that correct?
Yeah. Yeah. Cool.
It's a good question. So let's see if
we can get some metrics from this and
this may not even
work but let's see if we do top
node and top pod. Yeah. No metrics API.
Okay.
So that's probably why our autoscaler isn't kicking
in either as that we need to actually
provide a way to get metrics out of
this Kubernetes hasn't shipped with a default metrics
implementation
since
I'll throw one out there 1.9 something like
that. Everything that was later than that, but
everything's been extracted. So let's get the metrics
server running on our cluster first.
Please, if I don't explain anything, just prod
me.
So the metrics API,
that's what the
horizontal scale is looking for.
Mean, I don't I actually don't remember if
it uses the metrics server or not. I
believe it probably will.
It may do something cruder when it's not
available, but I'm gonna just I was just
wondering why that didn't like error when you
tried to spin it up if it didn't
have the server available.
Well, also, we don't even have any resource
constraints on our pods, do we? So what
50% utilization of what the full system?
Yeah that could take a while to get
to yeah. So there's loads of things here
that I'm obviously just
winging it. So let's go back to our
deployment, so we don't have any resource constraints
do we?
We do.
Okay. Yeah and they're not particularly great right?
So 50 meg of memory and half a
core which I'm assuming we're probably hammered in
that pretty well. So I'm gonna assume it's
just metrics server,
which we've already deployed to our cluster now.
That should mean
it's just not ready yet, so we'll give
it a little bit of time.
Let's see.
Metrics server.
So
the metrics server is gonna run-in the cluster.
It's gonna start scraping for stuff and this
should be exposed
soon.
He says hopefully. Hopefully.
The service isn't available yet so if we
just do if we actually do a cube
system
describe service
we should see the endpoints be added to
it once it gets past the liveness probes
that consider it healthy which could be anywhere
from ten seconds to a minute probably so
metrics
my service is called yeah metric service.
Alright So we need to wait for an
IP address to show up here.
Lots of waiting in Kubernetes, right?
At least it's all stuff it sorts itself
out with.
Yeah.
I'm far too impatient and just keep running
commands against my cluster. One of the things
I could do is check out the probes
on that metric server pod.
Yeah. Unhealthy at the moment.
How are the probes configured?
Ten second intervals waiting for one success.
Really should be healthy by now.
I wonder if this is where I found
out that the metrics server doesn't work with
Docker for Mac.
Let's try our service.
Yeah. Where's my endpoints? Come on.
Let's get the logs from it.
I don't really wanna debug this too much
but you can see we've got four restarts
on this. So I may switch to mini
cube if
that's gonna save us some pain.
But let's see what we're dealing with.
That's fun.
So it's failing because the certificate coming from
the API server doesn't contain the IP address.
Alright.
Let's switch.
1.10.
Let's not do that.
Alright.
We're spending up many cubes. That means I
will have to rebuild the images unfortunately.
But they should get as metrics ever running.
How come the images have to be rebuilt?
Aren't they stored on your local machine?
They are, but many cube runs inside of
a small virtual machine which won't have access
to my host.
Okay.
I mean, I can Some way of packaging
them up for export, isn't it?
I I could
save them to a tarball and import them
into the mini cube.
Would that save me time? I'm not really
sure.
I was kinda hoping Docker for Mac would
would just work
but I don't really wanna debug why a
metric server can't speak to it. I guess
while we wait for that we can just
quickly do Docker for Mac
metric server.
Someone's already written about this.
So
we're just they're just adding the and secure.
Oh, wait. Do not enable this.
That's just when it'll be accessed externally.
Alright.
Let's do it. Let's modify the metrics server
to accept that flag.
Makes that I'm pretty sure many cribs just
changed my context. Yep.
Proper desktop.
Get deploy,
edit, deploy
metrics,
server,
args,
next.
Done.
You feeling confident?
So
the next time you do a cube
cube CTL
apply,
would that not
override that config that's there? Probably, I'm just
not going to apply the metrics server again.
Right. Okay. But if if you were to
apply the metrics server again, would like nuke
whatever you changed. Oh, yeah. Definitely. It would
totally do But I do think we have
an endpoint now. So I'm glad we googled
that instead of rebuilding on mini cube.
Thank you code of Dan.
Okay. So
which means we have a metric server working,
which means we do have access to top
pods
and now we can actually see how much
CPU and memory is being consumed by our
Laravel application and how
much memory. So
we're actually only using one m cores
and 18 mega memory.
So oh, seat isn't running anymore.
And my port forward's gone. Too
many moving parts. Alright. Port forward to Laravel.
Laravel
example.
Eighty eighty.
Alright. That stays there.
Run siege.
Run top.
So we should just hopefully see this claim
as a request come in.
So that's gonna be a little bit late
and say in the metric server probably around
I can't remember what the default scrape interval
is gonna be, but let's assume thirty seconds.
Hopefully we see the CPU.
I mean it doesn't seem to get to
m previously
or we would have seen an auto scaling
event. So we may just tweak the resources
on it and force it to scale earlier.
Is it worth is worth making it so
it hits the one which hits the database
as well perhaps?
Yeah. So if you send it to slash
send your requests to slash posts instead of
just to the home page maybe. Is there
a watch on this? No. That would have
been too handy.
Can't you just wrap it in a watch
dash n one?
I could.
But then what would I type?
Oh, look.
Yeah. Nice. So that should auto scale then
now.
Yes.
Yes. Because it's made over 50% of the
allocated
resources.
I hope so.
Although not seeing another one spin up there.
Yeah. So the HP is gonna
wait for a few different data points there.
So
let's
double check.
These are limits. Yeah. Okay. So we we
should see an auto scale. I'm pretty confident
we'll see an auto scale.
I hope.
We'll let it do its thing and then
I'll maybe change it to the database end
points to see if we can port it
a little bit quicker
And then we'll actually do something a bit
more fun anyway. Like we wanna we wanna
start instrumenting this.
Oh, come on. Give me another pod.
Let's double check our HPA.
Why is that not coming up?
Are those old?
Yeah. I think so.
It says unable to get metrics for resource
CPU.
The age is only three minutes forty one,
though.
Yeah. I don't think we've been running metrics
Yeah.
Four minutes away. It's quite a while. So
I think it is working.
We're just not seeing a scale yet.
Okay. Let's try and force it before we
move on to the next thing.
Let's put this down to
100 which we know will cross pretty quickly.
But we are hitting the 500.
Alright. I'm gonna blame the HPA.
Question, Kieran, or just sign at my Yeah.
Is the when you when you set a
CPU limit I was trying to just ask
the stupid question.
When when you set a CPU limit,
that doesn't actually limit
the amount of CPU that that pod can
use. Right?
Because
we're talking about it going past the limit.
So is the limit just metadata?
No. We've got actually
an enforced limit of 500 m.
The CPU utilization
may not be on the limit actually, maybe
on the full host and we are blocking
it before it ever gets there. So I
guess in theory, why don't we just do
1%? Well, I guess my question is if
it's got a limit of 500 and we're
saying auto scale,
how would it ever get past 500 to
trigger auto scaling?
Yeah. Good point.
Trigger some person.
We're saying never use more than 500 and
then scale up if you go over 500.
So instead of using limits then, do we
need to use the requests?
Flag.
To be honest, I'm
making this up. I never used resource based
auto scaling because it's
well it's not ideal. So let's see if
we can get it working before we move
on though. So let's change us to just
requests
which means we want to make sure we
allocate half a core of a 50
memory.
How many cores have I given to Docker
for Mac? Let's let's check that first
and then we'll just give access to all
of them.
Come on Docker.
Well, popped open over there. Let's drag
my resources for Docker for Mac are eight
cores.
So I'm gonna give this the full thing.
The request of fail. I'll limit it at
that.
So let's reapply our PHP application.
I'm in the wrong directory.
Did you change it to be 1% was
when it scaled as well?
Yeah. I just wanna force it to scale.
That's all.
So I'm gonna run siege again.
We're gonna get pods.
Oh, looks like there was some stuff because
there's stuff terminating now.
Alright. Now it's scaling up. Okay. So now
we have triggered an artificial scale event. Now
the way that we interact and deal with
us in Kubernetes is just sort of this
describe command. So if we describe our horizontal
pod auto scaler, we should see threshold crossed
scale
event initiated and so forth. So
yeah, here we go.
So our new size was set to four.
The reason was that the CPU resource utilization
went above the target.
It's actually said that that's happened twice over
the last minute. So there we go.
That was easy. Once we got it
over a few little humps there.
Let's kill siege.
That should all scale back down because the
CPU realization will no longer being used.
Alright.
Not ideal, right? Like
CPU based scaling. I mean, I always think
the CPU is
indicative
of,
you know, we we can saturate it. So
it's an important thing to kind of monitor
and keep an eye on but not something,
you know, if we talk about scaling being
a proactive rather than reactive thing CPU seems
like something that is worst case. Oh no,
like we don't have enough CPU. We need
more. And of course if we're running out
of CPUs, we've got other challenges. So
what we actually want to scale on is
well, if we know the average response time
for our application,
then if it gets below a certain
service level agreement or objective, then we want
to scale up as well to try and
bring that back under the under the value
that we're happy with. Does that make sense?
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Totally. And CPU isn't
it's quite possible to have loads of CPU
left, but you've run out of network sockets
or
you've run out of processes or
Yeah. That's that's actually a fantastic point.
Thanks.
CPU is
CPU saturation is is one symptom but it's
not necessarily
what is
like, yeah. If we look at the response
time of a request that can actually be
the multiple symptoms could be driving that and
then that's that's better to monitor on.
Yeah. I was just thinking about a system
I worked on that had large binary downloads
and basically the network
card on the serve well, it's not a
real network card. The network could be capacity
of the server could be saturated and it's
not really doing anything. It's just serving a
big file.
Yep.
So what are you driving towards? You can
measure something better.
Yeah.
I mean I always think scaling
and monitoring is best done by our users
but we don't want them to report their
problem. We want it to be automated. So
for me I I wanna know
if I expect my PHP application to respond
in
eleven milliseconds or whatever siege was telling us
hopefully
then
we want to
monitor that going above what we expect and
scale it.
Okay.
Okay. We got a question from a Reza.
So run out of network socket, how does
Kubernetes gonna handle that? So there's two aspects
to auto scaling on Kubernetes.
The one we are focusing on today is
the scaling of the workload which means we're
gonna monitor for
metrics on the workload and our users to
scale those pods up.
If you want to monitor the platform to
scale the platform up then you have to
look at traditional
monitoring approaches like the
CPU, the network, the desk on your Linux
system and then horizontally scale the nodes in
your Kubernetes cluster to make sure you have
the capacity to scale the pods that are
running on the cluster.
Two very very different things
and maybe that's a good idea for another
episode but definitely not something we're gonna be
covering today
but I do love talking about monitoring in
general so.
Thanks for the question.
Okay. Let me see if I can find
any
sensible conscious human thought today.
There are two ways for us to get
some metrics out of our Laravel application.
One that involves us writing
code and modifying our application
and one that doesn't.
Keenan, you got a preference.
Alex, you got a preference.
If you can change no code and get
the same result, that's preferable.
It's also the dubious one, but I'm gonna
give it my best shot. So
because inevitably, when you get code required for
monitoring,
new sections of code might not monitor it
appropriately.
Whereas if it's automated
or
abstracted away, then it should be just handled,
and you're not relying on somebody doing that
work.
Yeah. Yeah. A lot of developers aren't thinking
about those concerns, are they, when they're writing
it? No. And you don't really want them
to think about that either.
I think we're gonna It should be it
should be a level of abstraction between
why it works in production efficiently
and why
like
you're coding it in a certain way, I
guess.
Okay. Let's try and do both. Right? I
think we've got enough time to do this
and
I think they're both valuable.
So when we run-in Kubernetes we actually have
access to a part and called a sidecar,
a sidecar means that we run an extra
container and the pod allows
that shares the same networking namespace, pet namespace
and a few others bits and pieces together.
One of the things that one of the
really useful use cases for that
is generally called service mesh even though I
don't want to use service mesh today but
I can still use that proxy effect to
capture all of the requests that come in
and out of our application.
In theory, what we should be able to
do is deploy linker d to this Kubernetes
cluster,
have it inject the proxy into our Laravel
application
and then have it expose response time metrics
on each request that comes out of our
container
without writing any single code. I think that
would be pretty neat. So
we'll give it a go.
Okay.
Pretty sure we don't need to use the
linker d
CLI
but
we may as well.
Why not? I'm pretty sure I can just
apply a manifest
rather than do this. I just don't know
if it's gonna be documented here.
Yeah. So we'll just move it to the
CLI.
Hopefully it's nice and quick.
I really need to start taking notes of
stuff to install before the streams like you
know all of sudden watching brew run.
How's brew on the m one Kieran? Is
it better? Is it fixed? Does it work?
How do you mean? I think when the
m ones first came out brew didn't work.
Oh yeah yeah. Well,
day one, I was able to get home
brew working.
But
at the time,
everything had to build from source. Okay.
And a lot of things believe that
they've released version three of Homebrew now, which
I think has resolved all of those problems.
Or like a lot of them anyway.
Yeah. Pretty much. So you could get Homebrew
two working really quickly and almost I I
got my
laptop a few weeks after they were available
and a few a few of the
packages had bottles already. They call them a
bottle. Right? The pre compiled thing.
Few of them had already got it, but
most of them are building from source and
it's just slowly been filling out.
And the ones that didn't build from source
got patched pretty quick. So with Homebrew three,
you don't have to I had a couple
of manual steps to install it, but you
don't need that anymore. It just works.
And anything that doesn't work, you can run
under as an Intel package anyway.
Yeah. It's got that translation there, doesn't it?
Yeah. Which works really well.
You don't you don't you're not really aware
of it. You can just run an intel
binary
and it transpiles it somewhere
and stores the transpiled version. Some magic somewhere
in
I mean, I don't want to Transpiles the
binary
to an ARM binary and stashes that away
somewhere for future use.
Yeah. I I don't I don't wanna segue
or deviate too much from what we're talking
about but like I read a really impressive
article where they were saying that the Rosetta
compilation translation and then running of the binary
was actually faster than some Intel chips
on the m one, which to me just
seems ridiculous.
That doesn't surprise me. Yeah.
Yeah. Let's go back Because the designing
because the chips designed for this use, there's
there's some instructions and a whole memory access
mode that's only there to make Rosetta work.
But if you're building an ARM chip from
scratch, you wouldn't have.
Okay. Cool. Alright.
I've taken the resources off of this just
so that we can have a better flexibility
as we deploy this.
I'm gonna reapply this. What we should see
is it's really nothing yet on directory
other than those resources being changed and we
can confirm that with a get pods
and you can see our application still has
two containers, which is NGINX and
FBM.
What we want to leverage with linker Dino
running in our cluster, I'm hoping that it's
healthy.
Maybe I should just check that anyway.
Yeah. Nice.
Is that we can now use something called
automatic sidecar
injection to add the third container to our
pod, which gives us all the proxy support.
I've never done this before,
but I'm confident.
So yeah, automatic proxy injection. I mean, I've
used like a d before. I haven't done
it quite in this scenario, so I'm sure
it'll be fine.
And all we need to do is add
an annotation
to our
manifest. In fact, here's one here
and we will change it to enabled obviously.
Metadata
annotations
enabled.
This should give us that third
container.
Well, that wasn't very nice, was it? The
documentation says something about rollout restart or something.
Yeah. The annotations, I don't think will trigger
the the so the way that this works
is that's a linker to the machine controller
in the cluster, which monitors for the deployment
being created.
I think if I just did this.
No. So that's
is this basically the Kubernetes version turn off
and on again, delete the pod and recreate
it?
I deleted the deployment. Yeah.
Alright. Maybe I need to enable linker Did
you do that production often?
Would I?
Yeah. Of course I would.
Alright. So why does it not work?
I can always do it the manual way
if I really need to, but I wanted
to use the nice shiny way.
Yeah. So let's just do it the manual
way. But this does it at a manifest
level rather than doing it through the admission
controller.
That's what I get for trying to do
something that I hadn't done before.
Resources,
ops,
deployment, Kubernetes
deployment.
And like a d inject, we'll add that
container and then we'll redeploy it.
And now we should have one.
So sucks that I had to do it
manually, but as long as we get it
working, I'm not too fast. So now we
have a third container.
And we don't need to describe it, but
you know, this is just a proxy
and what we really should see here is
if we color port forward and start that
again is that our application still functions as
normal.
I love it that my voice goes high
pitched when I see that as if it's
a question but. Yeah, that's normal.
Yeah,
as normal however
every request and
as going through linker d which
means if we pull and expose the metrics
from linker d we should be able to
see a little bit of information about how
long those requests take.
And I'm sure
there is a
command I can steal to do that too.
And metrics.
Yeah. There we go.
So
see.
Getting data from the proxies,
put forward. Oh, there is the UI as
well actually. I wonder if we could just
browse to the UI. We
all like UIs, don't we?
What's the namespace? Nope. Has it got its
own?
There we go.
Port forward.
Link to the web.
I really should have looked to see what
port it runs on. It was like four
two nine one, I think.
We're about to find out. No.
I was close. If you go to documentation,
was definitely a four involved.
Four one nine one. Okay. No. That's not
the UI port though. Oh, is it? Okay.
Right now. Yeah. So
Show
me the UI please. Please.
Might just gonna have to Google that linker
the UI. In fact,
might as well show people the Kubernetes we're
doing this right. You don't always need to
go to the dock. So we can see
that we have a pod here. We can
just describe it and see what ports are
available.
So
where
we got
ports
may actually be the port Either 4143.
So
4191.
On that on that documentation,
there's a something here which is exposing dashboard,
which is port eighty eighty four.
80 80 four. Eight
zero eight four. But I'm
not really sure what it's looking
at.
It's just called. We'll
get there. Okay.
This I'm not familiar with but I do.
I am. This is cool.
Let's see. Ritz.
Nope.
Is this just gonna be service meshy stuff?
Deployments.
Here's our Laravel application.
I can see our embed successes.
Oh, things are working well. I guess we
can break that with running siege.
Wait. Which UI are we looking at here?
Is this the Kubernetes
UI or is this Linkerd one? This is
Linkerd's UI. Linkerd.
Oh, it's just because it shows all that
stuff like the cron jobs and daemon sets
and deployments and stuff. Okay.
Yeah.
Because Linkerd can inject its proxy into any
of these resources. You can kind of break
it down and take a look at it.
So we can get let's go to our
route metrics.
We can see some stuff here. Okay.
Is it good? Does it drill down anymore?
No. Not really. What's this Grafana link? Does
it really deploy Grafana too?
That's not like it's just made your day.
That
is awesome.
Yeah. I should be more familiar with like
a d but I
I'm very impressed with that deploy
setting all of this up. That is awesome.
Alright. Let's run siege. Let's let's break this,
right? So
and
then we'll hook up the auto scaler to
it based on those metrics. So we
just wanna port forward to our Laravel application
again. I don't think I have that running
anywhere.
Pack a different port. 7,000.
I don't have it running. Okay. It doesn't
really matter though.
I got paired directory history as well. So
I need to go into the right directory
to get my command
now on 7,000.
Let's turn on refresh
last five minutes, refresh every five seconds. Let's
see if we can see some charts go
crazy here.
Can't believe it. Not only does it like,
so
by just running linker DNS cluster,
adding the proxy container.
We've got linker DUI showing which services are
communicating with each other. We've got Grafana provisioned
with pre canned dashboards to show us request
information and we can already see the latency
here spiking.
That's really cool.
That wasn't supposed to turn into a plug
for linker d but I feel like I'm
just gonna have to keep saying nice things
about it now.
So we can see all these metrics
going a little wild now so. So it
looks like latency is actually in hitting like
ten to twenty seconds.
Was that not two seconds?
Oh is it god I can't the resolution
is not great, is that? Yeah there's the
one downside to Grafana and zooming is
not great.
Just because it's so visual of course. But
yeah, that's two seconds.
Okay. Which isn't great but it's okay.
It's better than twenty It's great. Age.
Well, yeah.
Yeah. A page which returns to words like
hello world. That's it.
Okay. So one of the things we should
be able to do is
if we go to just
explore,
this is gonna give us raw access to
Prometheus and we should be able to query
the metrics that Linkerd is creating for us
for our service.
I kinda wish I had access to the
Prometheus UI, I'm not that we'll do it
from a dashboard right? Cause we know the
metrics that we want to monitor on which
is the,
we'll use latency for today.
So let's click edit on this and see
what that query looks like and then we
can use that as a basis for our
auto scaling. So
we can see here,
So the histogram ninety fifth percentile
is doing a sum across
rate interval
looking at response latency millisecond bucket
and it's doing the
rate over thirty seconds.
That kind of helps.
So we know that we have this available.
So I'm just gonna copy that metric name
and then
we're gonna go back to explorer
and just drop this in.
Go.
If there is a Prometheus install, is it
not going to be a Prometheus UI
also installed or
Don't get smart. I hope so. Maybe.
Why is that not running?
Oh, there we go.
So now we can see
we should be able to see
woah. Sorry. It's just been a bit slow.
Yeah. There we go.
There we go.
Alright. Cool. We got what we need. We
scale on that. I'm pretty confident.
And you were saying because we have
let's shut down siege just now. We probably
you're right. I think we do have a
link. We do have a permetheus.
So
let's try and get pods.
Prometheus.
So let's try that then. Linker d port
forward.
Oh, what's the iere fuse port?
Nineteen ninety.
Promise that's the last question I'll ask myself
in that
torn. Nineteen ninety. Yeah.
I copied that thing but we should see
I know we got this fancy thing, no
not fancy but you know we got a
list of all the metrics that we can
actually execute against.
The response time is the one we're curious
about so
yeah response time latency millisecond bucket
and we can use label selectors to filter
this but let's just get them all first
and then we can open this and we
want,
so we just want a Laravel application,
see what we have.
Namespace
default.
Maybe I don't remember how to do.
Is it equal since yeah. But we got
nothing.
Execute.
What's the name of spaces we've got here?
Linker d, link d. So it's just doing
the the proxy ones.
Do we actually have anything like yeah. There
we go. So
let's copy this.
So this is our application.
Oh, it's a long way down. There we
go.
Cool.
There we go.
This is just the stats that hit our
application.
Where's
the buckets?
Histograms normally have a
size.
Oh, l e one, l e two,
LE three. Okay, so this seems to be
the number of requests that took one second,
two seconds, three seconds, four seconds, five seconds,
ten, twenty, thirty, forty.
Those must be milliseconds
And we can see that nothing is taking
above
or no, maybe that's something else.
Above
infinite.
Okay.
This supposed me to explain how
histogram buckets work. Right? So this less than
is 50,000. I'm assuming that's milliseconds which
means that we are looking at
50 response time and then everything else is
in the plus infinity bucket. We seem to
actually have really even distribution
of the number, I don't think this is
actually the number of requests
and so we can always tweak that but
what's important is that we do have the
ability
to look at these metrics so
yeah here's our actual application.
Not sure why I'm not getting an idea
now though.
You've turned off your sage.
I know but I haven't started. There's been
no request last Oh, no request for last
minute. Yeah. Okay.
That's the refresh you just changed, not the
time.
I swear I've done this before.
It's definitely been Damon the last thirty minutes.
But you're the wrong namespace.
Alright. Okay. Doesn't matter.
We have metrics. We can scale. Now let's
go through the manual instrumentation of application using
a Laravel package
and then bring it back around to what
we actually wanna and then join all the
dots. Okay. So I think what I wanted
to show here, I got really sidetracked by
the shamely cool features was that we can
inject linker d,
enter a cluster,
automatically
inject a proxy and get a whole bunch
of HTTP and request based metrics out of
it that we can use for our HPAs.
Now what we wanna do as well, okay,
that's nice, but what if we wanna get
custom metrics out of our application
and the ways that we can do that.
Okay.
So
the standard way to do this
is just to expose, I mean we're still
put forward in our way. Yeah. But it's
on 7,000.
Yeah.
Normally what we do is just add a
metrics endpoint. So right now if we go
to slash metrics on our Laravel application, we're
not getting anything back whatsoever
and we wanna change that. Now
typically you don't need to write the instrumentation
for this yourself. There's generally middleware adapters for
like I think every language and framework I've
worked with in the past.
Someone has already written this and you just
have to bring in the package. So
this is where I'm gonna lean on both
of you. My PHP is incredibly rusty.
Good. But I did upfront Google Laravel
Prometheus
metrics.
There were a couple of packages, you can
see I've clicked on them.
Are you familiar with either either of these
developers and we have trust in them or
am I just picking the first one?
I don't know if either of them, so.
Which one has nice stars?
This one did. I think the other ones
are like 11. See I got Sophie's
Choice. It's like this one hasn't been updated
since March 2020 which is understandable given 2020
and then there's
It means it's stable.
Means it's stable. This one was updated more
recently but had less stars.
So
like that that that
Well we go with the recent one then
like stars aren't it. Stars don't actually mean
it's quality so.
No true.
Alright so
it looks like I mean,
I thought it was gonna only offer me
the get approach but we do have a
PHP way of doing this.
I don't even know if I have composer.
If you put it into
a
the composer. Json file and rebuild the image
it will put it in there. Yeah, good
call. I like that. Okay. So we could
just drop it in here.
I guess it would go here.
We don't need this star.
Can I just do latest?
No, just just put a star if you
want latest.
Okay.
Now I don't want to rebuild this image
too many times and we don't have, we're
not you know developing locally I don't have
PHP or anything like that so what I'm
gonna do is just
instrument it, hope that it works and then
we'll rebuild it there.
Okay.
So this then wants us to connect
this end
and to bootstrap app.
Sure I mean just keep me right here
in the Laravel bits, I'm just gonna trust
the documentation on this package for the time
being so.
I just drop it anywhere.
I mean this is an unusual way of
doing it but yeah.
That would normally not go in the bootstrap
file. Would normally go in
wanted to config file. There's config slash up,
which is where it would go. Sorry. Bootstrap
slash up. It would go in there.
That says bootstrap. Oh, wait. Oh, sorry. You
are there. Okay.
There's normally a massive array of them. One
minute.
I don't see that.
No. Sorry. If you go to config slash
app,
and then scroll down a bit, there's a
section called aliases.
You'd
normally put it in here. That's like the
standard way of doing it in Laravel. But
I assume there's a reason they haven't done
that because what they've done is more effort.
Right. I'm just gonna trust them. Just just
go with what they've got. I don't know
why they've done it, but they must have
done it for a reason. Okay. And then
we have to register.
I mean, I don't even know if that's
gonna just be lumped together here. If there's
any ordering constraints,
like, I put it to the bottom or
We're gonna think that. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Guess.
So this package has a default configuration, which
is just the environment variables.
So we just need to do a little
bit of tweaking and then
or does this actually want us to do
something else to to customize
dot ENV. Do we have a dot ENV
that goes into the container?
Yep.
In fact, I can just put these in
the deployment like this
yeah.
That's one of the things we did last
time was we set it up with a
config back, didn't we?
Did we? Did we? We did. Nice. Cool.
Oh, yeah. And there's those secret things. But
that's all we shut down now so it's
okay.
So profifi is namespace
that's gonna need tweets. That's not where we've
not really deployed our own premiFUS yet but
we can do that for sure. Just we'll
piggyback on the linker d one.
I'm assuming we want to enable route based
metrics.
Yes. Although I mean if these are the
defaults I probably don't need to provide them
right?
Depends obviously it depends whether Dave
might. You mean you don't understand how this
random package that you've never seen before that
I've just presented to you works?
Yeah basically.
Right okay.
Prometheus metalware
now.
Don't know what you are. Don't know what
you are.
Don't know what you are.
Prometheus reddest.
So this is yeah, this is where things
get a little weird in PHP land. I
never really thought about upfront and I really
should have but Prometheus has counters that usually
are stored in memory and then PHP with
its CGI share nothing kind of approach
probably wants us to have a Redis to
be able to cache those counters so they
don't get reset to zero every time.
So
we'll probably just need to quickly throw a
Redis us into this as well.
Is
the idea that it periodically would export so
it keeps that state somewhere in the application
then periodically exports it to Prometheus?
Yes, so the way that Prometheus
works is it's a pill based system that's
gonna come to our application on the metrics
endpoint every ten or thirty seconds.
We're gonna have all these counters that we
need to process across multiple requests.
Redis is gonna have to make that work.
Okay. So
we'll,
we're gonna pay it back on Linkerd. Right?
So let's do Linkerd.
Doesn't seem to allow me to
specify the name or where that Prometheus is.
But that's not important because Prometheus is gonna
come to us.
Oh, I'm so confused.
Because we can't we can't configure the target.
I'm just gonna deploy Prometheus. That's gonna be
easier. Yeah.
Is pretty much getting started to get the
docs deploy the manifest
and most people would probably go down the
route of configuring the
operator. Maybe that's easier. Kubernetes.
Prometheus
operator.
Let's just deploy that.
Quick start bundle
bundle.
There we go.
Okay.
Apply
our bundle.
Very trusting. I have no idea what's in
this file.
But
the previous operator will give us a CRD
approach to request new Prometheus servers and then
configure them using something called a service monitor,
which is just another CRD.
In fairness, I do think this is the
quickest way probably for us to get this
working. We applied it to the default name
space, so we should see our operator running
here.
Now we need the YAML to ask for
one Prometheus.
Let's jump back to the docs.
Guess we'll just get it from the gate.
Nope.
Get me a Prometheus.
There's a service monitor. That's good.
And
there's a Prometheus.
Okay.
We'll add it to our ops Kubernetes.
Now we have this dependency that we're not
gonna automate in any way, but I'm just
gonna add the CRD, which says give me
one Prometheus.
We'll call it Prometheus.
Service monitor selector.
We just, that just means we need to
remember to add team front end to our
service monitor.
I think that should be all right. Let's
find out. So we'll get to the right
directory. There's a lot of just let's find
out, isn't there? I'm sorry.
And the operator should detect the CRD
and should
spin this up one Prometheus,
Assuming I have a go anything wrong very
quickly there.
I would have expected to see my Prometheus
already.
Did I get anything wrong?
I don't think I need to add my
service monitor first
but I will just in case.
Laravel,
We've added the label that expects.
Now we want to point it to our
application. So if we take a look at
our deployment,
we have this label
and we can just match that straight up
and it's using a named port to work
out how to fetch those metrics.
So we just need to make sure that
our port is named,
which is not, but we could just do
that.
Oh no, because I don't wanna reapply this
because of the sidecar.
So we'll just do port 80 like so.
Yes? Okay. Alright. I was gonna say, is
you've got the service monitor's name as Laravel.
Does that need to match the Laravel example
project or is that its own thing?
Or line four.
I know that that's okay. So the Prometheus
is doing a service monitor based on the
label team front end which I've kept the
same here. So Okay.
That just means that our Prometheus
should detect that service monitor which will add
it as a scrape target to our Prometheus
which hasn't magically shown up yet disappointed and
pulling our metrics. So
why do I not have a Prometheus?
Let's grab the logs as quickly and see
if there's anything obvious.
Okay. What have I forgotten?
Operator, deploy and manage previous server. Yep. That
would be nice.
Let's see.
One of them's got operated, not operator.
Does that matter?
So
that service tells me that it's tried to
create our Prometheus.
Maybe just failed.
K. Get service monitors.
Laravel.
Let's describe it.
It's alright.
We just don't have
Prometheus.
I'm just gonna deploy my own Prometheus.
And then I'm just clicking on random links
looking for YAML.
Pretty much sums up my job as well
to be fair.
Kind deployment.
Nope. Not there. Next.
Deployment for me, I there's nothing particularly special
about it.
Nope. I want the YAML.
Kubernetes.
Nope.
I'm not enjoying computers
today.
How old is this? 2018.
That's probably not the wisest thing to go
through on my cluster is it?
What have I missed? What have I been
silly with either of you?
I have no idea.
So we installed the operator and it's happy.
It's definitely happy.
I found something which has the word deployment
in it and the word Prometheus as well.
You want more YAML to throw a wall
that might, don't know.
Hold on.
Let's do get Prometheus. So we we had
our CRD and we requested a Prometheus. We
could see that we have no version and
no replicas. Right? That's that's bad.
So we're gonna describe our Prometheus and see
if there's any events on it.
I'm really regretting calling it Prometheus. So I
I think it's failing because the service account
doesn't exist.
So let's use the default service account
and
see if that keeps it happy.
So now we can just redeploy our prometheus.yaml
once I learn how to computer.
And then we're on get prometheus.
There we go. So it was Okay. Service
account. I'm
not a failure. Okay. So
I
don't know why the operator wasn't printing anything
out to say, hey, the service account doesn't
exist. You're not gonna get your Prometheus regardless.
This is gonna configure us a Prometheus and
our namespace with a service monitor that monitors
our Laravel application.
That monitoring is gonna fail,
we'll actually be able to see that through
the Prometheus
UI.
So
let's jump into that very quickly before we
deploy our PHP changes.
What you should see here is in targets.
I was kind of hoping the surface monitor
would have picked that up.
Maybe I broke that too.
Let's see.
This is just not showing them.
Okay. I think it's trying. Okay. But we
don't we don't have anything there for it
to work. So
let's make the change that we need to
make for our application to have that endpoint.
So let's go back to those environment variables
on our deployment or config map. Apologies.
Oh yeah. We know we need a redis.
Right.
Redis Kubernetes.
Just give me a YAML,
a Redis pod. Am I feeling that bold?
Yeah.
What's the worst that could happen?
That's a really stupid idea.
I'm just gonna do it.
So that should give me one Redis.
I feel I don't know. It's
one available is we probably wanna make that
available to service. Yeah. That is a really
stupid idea. I don't even know why I
entertained that. Okay. Next.
Helm. I should just do the proper relation
there.
So Do we need to worry about it
back to saying it's deprecated?
No. It's okay.
Okay.
Seems like such an overhead, doesn't it, to
deploy Redis
just for this?
It is again, it's only in PHP because
of the share nothing thing
it is a bit of a pain in
the ass but we're just gonna go with
it and the deprecation warning here is because
I know you can't really do URL and
I can't zoom in on the URL bar
but this is helm slash charts on GitHub
which is deprecated but it's actually pointing us
to the bitnami one which is not deprecated
so. Okay. It's okay
And we'll call our helm. I will call
our reddish reddish.
So are we gonna have one reddish.
We're gonna have one reddish per pot.
No. We're just gonna run one reddish in
our cluster
and then
our PHP application is gonna use that for
cache and persistence of Prometheus counters.
What this should mean is we have a
Redis
service here which I can now point our
PHP application
use.
So Redis master
or head in fact, probably wants the headless
service, so let's do that.
So now we need to compare to our
config map
and our Redis is available on Redis.
Let's point it to the master. I think
that's what I was gonna expect. Our Prometheus
now lives in our namespace.
Let's call that default.
This
may work.
Confident.
I definitely lack any confidence today.
So now that we've modified this config map,
we can apply that first
and
nothing should actually happen yet because those keys
won't be,
aren't gonna be consumed by our PHP application.
However,
what we want to do now is rebuild
those images with that code change that we
made.
Did we finish the code change? Were we
confident there?
I think did you make your way through
the entire file?
So
what's this suggesting?
Do I need do I need this load
component thing?
It
says to customize
the configuration you either need to override the
environment variables which I've done
or you can copy the included permetheus dot
PHP
to this location edit it and then use
it.
Yeah, we don't need that. Yeah, just copy
that and see what happens.
No. You
want you want the middle one as well.
Okay. So now we have to add this
also to our bootstrap at PHP and again
I have no idea whether ordering is important
so.
Just put it below, it came below in
the documentation.
That's kind of the the same logic I'm
using right now. To observe guzzle. We don't
we don't care about guzzle, we're not doing
API calls.
Alright.
We do have
database providers so let's get those metrics too.
I mean if this application is doing all
the things that suggest it's doing that would
be really nice. So
I wonder if we could just abuse the
disk rather than Redis. In fact it does
mention APC here and there's a memory adapter.
So maybe we can maybe there was a
way to do this without Reddit. Yeah. Oh.
Alright and then that's the Cool. You could
probably use op cache as well.
Yeah. I think I think that would make
a lot of sense too.
Alright. Let's rebuild our images and we're just
gonna see what happens here. Alright. Fingers
crossed.
Hopefully the
I was gonna say hopefully the NPM one
won't need to do anything because there's been
nothing that's changed in our
assets. But I'm guessing
I think something's changed.
We're copying everything. Right. So we've been validated
the cache, aren't we?
What a crappy Docker fail. Who wrote that?
I don't know. Yeah.
We actually Kieran and I did an episode
on really
nailing down how to have an optimized cache
for bug and PHP applications. I'm not sure
why we
didn't copy that here.
If I didn't write this one, that was
you Alex, wasn't it? I wrote this one.
It's a copy of the stream that me,
you and came and did ages ago.
Well, we did. Last October.
There was a copy of that. Oh, yeah.
So the problem is I think you've done
the multiple copies but we've not got the
steps.
Oh no wait. Oh that's dev. So
oh yeah. You have to run the the
composer install here.
After the
That's all. Yeah.
No big deal. It won't take too long
and then what we'll do is I won't
bother reinjecting the linker deep proxy and we
sit, we sit, we see not working so
let's just leave it out, we'll apply our
manifest over the top
and then we will confirm that the metrics
endpoint on our Laravel application works. Once we
confirm that,
that's that's pretty much it. Once those metrics
are available, we can figure the HPA the
same way that we did at the start
instead of using CPU, we're gonna point it
to custom metrics
and it should just work. TM.
The shame a little discord chat thing is
not working.
I'll try it again.
Oh well.
We broke it. Oh no.
So what's that complaining about there?
Complaining about illuminate foundation application with facades.
Yeah. Okay. So that that's
before when I was saying this is a
really weird way of doing it. That'll be
why it's weird. Because because it's not a
valid way of doing it looks like.
You
yeah.
Is it worth maybe bringing this into a
separate
into a separate stream at some point, like,
use an application level
metrics? Because
I don't think that that package works.
What?
All of those methods, like, with facades and
stuff, they don't seem to be
like, that's not how I would ever register
things.
Okay. I'm gonna take it out. I'm gonna
feel brave here. So hold on.
I've had that as
Alright. Let's use this one. Okay. We tried
you one. Yeah. Cool. Yeah. Is the normal
way of doing things. Seem to be the
same. So let's let's trust it. And if
it doesn't work, it doesn't work. We'll move
on. No big deal. Mhmm. Okay.
So I need to modify the composer dot
JSON.
Yep.
So,
and then in our app dot PHP we
add a provider. So this is config
slash app, not the bootstrap app which you
were in before.
Okay.
So I can just put it anywhere here?
But the bottom, but yeah.
No. That's the wrong one. Sorry. There's two
arrays go to the top of it. The
first array and put that one in.
Yeah. Here.
And then
you got random.
Yeah. Yeah. Cool.
And then we add this one to the
aliases.
Actually, this seems very similar.
It's very similar but that's the correct way
of doing it. I don't know. I assume
this is maybe a fork where they've modernized
it or something maybe.
Hopefully that You've got a rogue closing bracket
there as well by the way. So you
might get rid of that. Why did they
keep copying them?
Or did I paste the wrong thing? I
think I think that one there was when
the first one you copied had you highlighted
two lines. I think that's what it was.
Alright. Are these the same? Prometheus namespace yeah.
I think they are.
Let's check the config map. The reddish is
different. They're
just using this.
Which is standard
Laravel.
So previous namespace metrics were enabled and metrics
route path.
Yes. Yes. It does want this. I'm just
gonna throw that in very quickly too. Even
though I killed in the last example
and then read this host red is port,
red is host and red at port. Yep.
You've need to put the prefix one back
in I think and the storage adapter.
Oh, the storage adapter. So that will make
it
not
that would make it not use Redis, would
it not? If he was Well, they seem
to use both. So I'm gonna that this
person knows what they're doing.
Because I have no idea what I'm doing.
So Redis
master.
And why am I getting red squiggles everywhere?
It's specified twice.
Thirty three and thirty six and thirty four.
Okay. Now it's happy.
We have a comment that I don't understand.
Hopefully one of you too, but Jake Harris
says 2021 and no auto discovery dance game.
I don't know. Yes. So in like Laravel
05/2006,
like about four years ago,
service providers were auto discovered.
So you don't have to do that stuff
where you added to the aliases just by
having a composer file. Having it in your
composer file would make it work. I'm guessing,
but he's just on about the fact that
it's not been, you know,
updated to have that stuff done.
Okay. So
FPM failed again.
And that looks like it didn't
pull in the composer.
Put in the package.
Do I need to delete the lock file?
No. Is it doing a compression install or
compression update?
I don't know.
In the j, in the Docker file.
Install preferred desk, no lens, no dev.
So delete the lock file.
Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know how it handles copying the
file that doesn't exist.
Alright. Fingers crossed.
It doesn't. Just I thought it might not.
Oh, Chris is back. Alright. Okay. Yeah. There
is a copy.
Yeah.
We'll get there.
I know we're we're over time for today.
So if either of you need to drop,
feel free.
I'm gonna go whenever. Alright.
Alright.
I'm gonna We have hit a lot. I
do actually have to go because I've got
a call in five minutes. Yeah. No worries,
mate. Thanks for tuning in and joining us.
Yeah.
I added a lot. Thanks for having me.
No worries. See soon. Okay.
So
what happened here then?
So this is saying that
the package
it can it basically can't resolve our dependencies
because we're using
a newer version of Guzzle
than what they basically, this is a package
that isn't up to date with
dependencies and stuff.
Is that maybe why someone forked it?
Well, yeah.
But then the one that's forked is
worse. I'm just gonna try and configure the
fork then the way the other one is
configured because it's so similar that I can't
can't see why it wouldn't work. Right?
Okay. Yeah. And if it doesn't work, you
know what? We'll come back to it another
day.
But I'm gonna give this my best shot.
If anyone watching has
added Prometheus to their application, feel free to
throw some advice our way.
Alright. So we wanna add something to contact
app aliases, which we did previously.
Wrong code.
To me, this just looks like it's screaming
out for somebody to write a new
and better package.
Yeah. It's kind of the vibe I'm getting.
That's the wrong one.
Could be a fun
could be a fun project to do, I
guess.
But, yeah, most of this was modified two
years ago. Bits of it were changed five
months ago, but
Okay. So I've added the alias.
We need to register this,
which seems to be done in its own
way,
but we copied, you know, we saw that
up here.
And
I think I already modified composer dot JSON
but I'll double check.
Yes. Just one second. What version of Laravel
are we using? Can you check the composer
dot JSON file?
Right.
Yeah. This won't work.
The package hasn't been updated. It's only it
only seems to support version seven, and there's
an there's an open
issue on there for supporting seven. So
So does that mean there is
there is no working Prometheus Laravel package?
It certainly looks that way from a cursory
look at Google. Yeah.
Laravel.
I find that hard to believe.
Would that be an alternative instead of Prometheus,
like
that is done by somebody or maybe?
So I mean I can definitely walk through.
Why don't we add a manual metrics endpoint
for now? Can show people
I mean it's so easy right,
these packages are supposed to make it
automated and that you know the metal where
we'll hook out to the request pipeline see
the request coming and take a timestamp see
the request going out take a time stamp,
hold them in memory and then drop them
into a page right. But Prometheus metrics
are not difficult so let's remove
this,
let's go back into our config, let's remove
all that stuff as well.
Really disappointed there wasn't just a make it
go package.
One thing we could Yeah. Just looked like
there was one that's
an opening in the market of
packages where
it'd be a nice nice thing to fill.
We could instrument through open telemetry
which is another really really good approach for
doing distribute iteration in your application. It's not
what I'm trying to show today so I
won't do that. We'll add a custom metrics
endpoint right now
and then we'll wrap up for today and
I think we'll come back and we'll revisit
you know maybe even you and I can
sit down and write a Laravel middleware to
do this like I said it is not
difficult.
Yeah, no I'm down for that because
writing Laravel packages is quite fun so.
Okay.
Let's save all of this. I'm gonna close
all my tabs. How do I add a
new route to my Laravel application?
Okay. So go to routes/web.PHP.
Okay. Next. This is kind of a caveman
approach but
I'm okay with caveman approach because we are
over time but I wanna try and get
something working. So
how to
You want it to be a get request
then get
the path and then Is there no shorthand
functions and text in PHP?
There is. I just don't use it because
it's PHP
eight and some of our stuff is still
using PHP seven point stuff.
Okay. Can I just use print here?
So like
what do you want to do? Just get
like a string on the page? I just
wanna return a plain text string. Okay. Return
double quote string in there and double quotes.
That's it. Does PHP have string literals, multi
lane strings?
Yeah. So it's Oh, Christ. How do you
do that? Three left Chevron's
Chevron's.
Really? I have to do it here doc?
I believe that's how you do it. Yeah.
Well, you can do double quotes and pull
out in multiple lines if you want to.
That's
Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So let's
try and get that response time here. These
are just Prometheus metrics, there's nothing fancy here
and then I can do one,
I can add metadata to this, I could
say app is Laravel.
And this was gonna be a histogram. I
would add my buckets, so we'll see less
than one,
two second responses, three second responses.
We'll assume that, you know, a 20 requests
of 28
requests of command and we responded under one
second. We've had four or two requests that
took two seconds and one request that took
three seconds. That's it. That is a met
that is a metrics endpoint. Obviously we'd want
real data.
Yeah. Why is my end of here doc
not working?
So you need to put a semicolon at
the end of it. I tried that.
And also semicolon after your Monday.
Got it. Thank you.
So obviously we've actually went to middleware to
track how many requests are fitting into each
bucket. We can also add any arbitrary metric
here that we want and we could do
HTTP
version
at
Laravel
PHP 7.4.
And another thing we could do is
users
Name name equals David. And we had two
Davids. Right?
Completely random.
And but this is all our metrics endpoint
is is something that fits this form and
then we can deploy it. So I'm gonna
hopefully
build this image deploy it, hit metrics endpoint.
Prometheus hopefully if I'm not messing up enough,
we'll scrape that based on the service monitor
that we created
and we could use that for an HPA.
That's kind of where I want us, hopefully
be finished in the next
five minutes confidence.
Okay.
And maybe I'll get some lunch today.
It's quarter four if you're eating anything yet.
It's been a busy day.
So
Jake Harris, I think he's picking up the
gauntlet and is gonna attempt to magic us
a Prometheus middleware from Laravel that would be
amazing and Alex and I would both be
happy to help, please feel free to link
us to any repository or any efforts.
Okay.
Now that we have a new image we
just wanna redeploy
all of our manifests,
hopefully I've not broken anything in there during
this kind of hectic component
and then we're gonna do a get pods.
Let's see,
four seconds, that's good. So we have got
a deployed application.
Gonna port forward
to Laravel
example.
Let's see if eighty eighty is available. Yep.
We should have our application
and we should have,
We don't get new lines or is that
just my browser?
If you've used our. Okay. Cool. Yeah. Usually
if I must be my Chrome has a
primipious extension that formats metrics but oh well.
Okay.
That's I mean, wish I could say it's
there's more magic than this but that's all
the metrics endpoint is. Obviously you want the
numbers to be real, you want the dimensions,
the metadata
to be vast and understand your application, you
can expose as much context as you want
here that you want to be able to
query slice and dice with from a monitoring
perspective.
You'd also want it to be behind some
form of authentication I guess wouldn't you? Some
sort of like,
you wouldn't I mean you may only want
to respond on a local internet address like
the you know, the Kubernetes
and pod or service ciders, sure. 10. Something
or whatever. You might not want to, yeah,
you probably don't want it to be exposed
to your public end using customers. Yes. But
I wouldn't
necessarily put it behind off, I would probably
just
Firewall or something. Okay, something like that. That's
a whole, I mean there's so many different
approaches to that but let's cover that later.
Okay. Let's see if our service monitor works.
So
let's see.
Describe
service monitor Laravel.
Hopefully
let's get our Prometheus up and running again.
Did I still have that port forwarding?
I can't even remember what my port forwards
are anymore. It was like ninety one ninety
one I think for that one. That's linker
d. Okay. Let's close them. Let's port forward.
I know. You need some
you need to get on the
screens
or t mux.
I can't I can't stand t mux. Okay.
How come?
I just break scrolling. Scrolling becomes really cumbersome
on it. Oh yes. It's like can be
left square bracket and yeah.
I wish my service monitor was working.
So what is the service monitor trying to
do?
Okay. So Prometheus is a pool based system,
which means that Prometheus has to know which
pods within our cluster should be, they should
fetch metrics from.
It does that should the Prometheus operator monitoring
for our service monitors here
and
those service monitors tell how to find things
that expose previous metrics and then updates the
targets and then it should just work.
But where have you told it to go
to slash metrics?
Okay. Let's let's double check my configuration. So
we added something to our resources
here in Prometheus.
We told it to find Laravel example application
use port 80 and that's gonna go to
the pods and this application on port 80
and fetch slash metrics.
Oh it doesn't that slash metrics by default?
Yes.
Okay. Right.
So
labels team front end
exist
should be going to this Prometheus.
So we can double check that we have
this label on our deployment. I'm pretty sure
we do.
Yeah. Think you copied that one. Yep. And
our pod gets it too, which is perfect.
And the port is 80.
The port is 80.
Yep.
Oh is it getting is it getting that
from
don't matter if it goes via the NGINX
to FPM does it? That doesn't matter.
No because we hit that in the browser
so it should be okay. Yeah.
So
let's port forward to Prometheus again.
Which
let's see.
Service discovery.
That seem to be picking up some Laravel
configuration.
Oh, that's the job.
Why is it going to the job?
Wonder if it has the same labels on
it.
Oh, it probably does.
Alright, let's try it. It was a generic
label and not specific for web or anything.
Okay let's add Promise.
I don't know why but I'm gonna add
it
and see if that tweaks our configuration.
Let's modify this here So
instead of going here we'll do this
and we'll do the same.
Well, in fact that's okay. Yeah. That should
hopefully work.
Who knows at this point, right? So let's
apply everything.
Oh. Did not allow that. Yeah. It's okay.
Let's just delete or deploy.
Okay.
We'll give that a second. Hopefully just
fat. Yeah. It's almost healthy already. So we
have a comment.
No. I know. Says open telemetry for PHP
is very new. So waiting on GRPC
and the PHP package to help with direct
integration with Honeycomb.
Yes. Honeycomb is a great front end for
open telemetry and distributed traces and structured events.
Really cool.
Just really cool product. Definitely worth checking out
in this space
and open telemetry is new all around the
board.
They are starting to stabilize on their APIs,
they have caught up with a lot of
the feature gaps that they had during the
migration from open census and distributed tracing open
tracing.
Yeah, it's worth checking out and I think
instrumenting your application open telemetry now is
definitely the safest way to move forward.
Alright. Let's see what happens. Let's go back
to our targets.
Prometheus, you're really annoying me today. I
wonder if we can just do this old
school style. Prometheus
annotation.
There used to be a way where you
could just add an annotation to your pod
and tell Prometheus to go find you.
May still work at all the service monitors
are the replacement for that so we'd begin
to fix it. But I'm also worried about
time here.
We're way over where we wanna be. So
let's see if we can get any more
information from that service monitor.
Laravel.
Okay.
No is working on an open telemetry package.
GitHub slash Sean hood slash. You know what?
I actually came across that and opened it
earlier.
Your package. I haven't opened on my other
browser.
I was gonna show this off today but
I hadn't,
I didn't really want to go into the
open telemetry stuff but we both definitely do
more on open telemetry over the coming weeks
so yeah,
cool that you're working on that package.
Okay, service monitor.
Promo labels, yes
port 80 should be fine.
What we can do is take a look
at the logs which I know failed as
measurably earlier on the operator.
Yeah, that logging is crap.
I'm gonna restart it
just for the sake.
Let's see if it reconfigures the Prometheus
thing. I mean it should be dynamic.
Start everything. Right? So
Yeah. It went last time.
Okay. So
I'll go check our targets.
So where it says zero out of 11
active targets that mean that it's not finding
how to access those 11.
Yeah. It's the service monitor is not picking
up our application whatsoever.
So which is frustrating.
Anyway,
think we'll just need to leave it there.
Not as successful as I was hoping.
I think there is a lot. Let me
drop off our empty slot there. You know,
we're bigger. Right.
That should have been a lot easier. I'm
not happy
with
with the challenges that we came across.
Know, Jake, you know, you said you're gonna
give that a go. Think maybe this is
just Laravel. I think Symphony possibly
has better support with Prometheus exporters.
I know when I did a little bit
of Googling just to see if these existed
in the PHP ecosystem,
there weren't a lot of options
but
this is gonna save you from instrument in
your code yourself, know you don't really want
to add your own slash metrics endpoint and
be and be writing those out. You really
want the middleware to do it all for
you. OpenTelemetry is a good way of doing
it. We did have success with BlinkerD and
automated proxy metrics which was sweet and
so I think based on what we've seen
today that the best way forward until
Jake writes his new million dollar library and
start selling it to people
would be to go down the automated proxy
approach because
the most valuable metric you can scale on
is how long does it take to respond
to 95%
of my customers
and am I happy with that number? And
when the answer is no,
scale up.
So Alex, how are you feeling with our
auto scaling now?
So we managed to the only actual auto
scale successful auto scaling we had today was
the one that you said started off by
saying that you didn't like doing, which was
the
the one based on requests
and limits. Yes.
The horizontal autoscaler in Kubernetes.
Yes. So there's definitely more that we can
do on this.
Because you mentioned a few times about doing
custom metrics and things to scale based on
responses from Prometheus or whatever.
Uh-huh. So let me just show how that
would have worked.
You know, if we had a Laravel package
that was exposing Prometheus metrics and our service
monitor was being picked up and that was
available and I could query those metrics in
Prometheus.
What I would have wanted, what I would
have done next is deploy the Prometheus adapter
to our Kubernetes cluster.
The Prometheus adapter is what exposes
new or fat any adapter for the metric
server is what exposes new custom metrics that
can be used in the HPA rules.
In fact, I have it already in the
demo directory I think and I want that.
Nice to smart down. Okay. Hopefully there's some
YAML down here but this would have allowed
me to use custom metrics to do the
HPA.
Let me see if I can zoom in
on this where we would have been able
to instead of using the CPU utilization
on the HPA object is actually used rules
which identify a series which would have been
our HTTP response time and we would have
told it to you know perform a query
against that and try and get what is
that percentile very much like the query that
we copied from the Grafana dashboard that linker
deep provided to us, know we want to
understand percentiles
you know we can't give everybody
thirty second and forty millisecond response time but
we wanna try and ensure we get as
many people into that bucket as possible.
So hopefully
once
we find a Laravel package that works and
we can retry this again, we'll be able
to get to the stage where we can
deploy the Prometheus adapter configure a new HPA
and take it from there.
All I can hope for the people that
have watched us throughout this is that, you
know, hopefully the components and primitive required to
do horizontal scaling on Kubernetes are now more
familiar to you. You know the right words
to Google and you know which package you
need to exist in order to get those
metrics out of your application
and even using the could be as well
where wherever
possible. So
well we were unsuccessful, I
hope there was enough there for people to
get interested.
Yeah. So in terms of losing linker d,
would you use that alongside or instead of
something like click d stats d
or are those not really relevant at all
when you're dealing with Kubernetes compared to a
standard VM?
Yeah. I'm I'm unlikely to use collect your
stats D. Those are, you know, platform or
host based monitoring. They're not really application level
stuff although you can't use them in that
regard.
Prometheus being a CNCF graduated project,
a lot of people are just running it
on Kubernetes because of the time away the
Prometheus operator
does work when you get the service account
right.
The service monitoring I'm sure is my editor
and I'm sure when I rewatch this to
type up the, you know, the timeline for
the description, I'll see the stupid mistake that
I've made but obviously right now I'm not
seeing that.
No, don't see it either. So yeah.
It might be might be worth when we
think about what the mistake is to put
a
a snippet like
in description or something maybe. Well yeah all
of the resources that we have created even
the broken ones for now will be pushed
to your repository which is in the show
notes. It's also github.com/go
for Alex.
Alex Bowers slash Laravel example project probably. So
it's in the show notes. Alex Bowers will
be the one that's on there with the
most recent push on it So Yeah. So
all this stuff will be there.
Hopefully the Laravel situation improves and we'll do
a second part of this and thank you
all for watching and thank you Alex and
Kieran has left, but thank you for joining
me and
having some fun.
Thank you. Alright. Have a great day. I'll
speak to you soon. Bye. Yep. And you.
Bye.